let's go next to
um why don't we go to max
from illinois max from illinois you're
on the air
hi david uh hello thanks for having me
on pleasure
um i called you in or i called in to you
about
a year-ish ago um but uh just to briefly
sum it up i pretty much was having an
issue with my family
where uh they were all convinced that
joe biden was the only person who could
win
in 2020 i suppose they were
correct in some sense i remember the
call i remember talking to you about
this
so i find myself in a new position now
where anytime i even
mildly critique biden yeah uh they call
me a trumpus
and assume that i'm coming at it from a
right-wing perspective right even as i
try to explain my left-wing perspective
yeah that's you know i've dealt with
this a little bit during my
you know during the trump era i would
cover the press briefings of kaylee
mcinanni or mckennany or marganani as
some of them call her
and i would just give my thoughts in
real time and
similarly now under biden i will cover
the gensake press briefings
and of course gensake is not a liar like
kaylee mcinanni was
the uh substance the level of substance
is up dramatically
with gensake relative to kaylee mcinanni
you know it's
it's like a 9010 it's a huge difference
but sometimes jen saki will like not
really answer a question or she'll say
something that doesn't make sense like
for example
the biden tax plan will not increase
taxes
on individuals nor on families earning
under four hundred thousand and someone
will ask well hold on is it is the is it
on individuals or or families because
usually for families it's twice the end
of it
and jesus it's both and it's like that
doesn't make any sense and i'll point
that out
and i'll get emails from people saying
how dare you
how dare you criticize jen saki she's
great
and it's like guys you know nope none of
these people are infallible and just
because we point out that something
doesn't make sense doesn't mean that
we're on the right all of a sudden
yeah um and that's kind of the argument
i've tried to make
though i i met with a lot of resistance
yeah
i don't know what to do to deal with
that because it's like do you have to
clarify every time
just to be i you know it's like in
family are you do you have to say
i support joe biden over trump and
thought trump was despicable
but when joe biden said x i don't think
that that was accurate like that's a
crazy way to have to communicate
especially with family
i agree though it's what i'm doing
currently oh it is that's how you do it
you frame it that way
i pretty much have to um and you know
they
they're a little bit more responsive you
know at least when i tell them i did
vote for biden but it's
it's a lot of the same of oh no biden's
basically infallible
yeah if you find some way to better uh
grease
this the wheels on those conversations
let me know
for sure thanks david all right my
pleasure great to hear from you yeah
that's that's uh that's a sad
set of uh circumstances that's for sure
um
okay why don't we go to john paul jones
now john paul jones i remember we've
spoken before because you didn't know
that the led zeppelin bassist was john
paul jones last time you were on right
um hey david um thanks for having me on
um
yeah i just wanted to say a few a couple
couple of things first of all first of
all i just wanted to say say
thank you for talking me out of
considering in voting for third party
last summer that wasn't the main reason
why
i backed away from voting from third
party but that was kind of
the thing that puts me over dx like no
i'm not going to do that so
i just wanted to say thank you for that
thank you and then awesome
um also also i just wanted to say i'm
actually
start i'm in the process of starting a
new progressive
blog right now for my self and i just
was wondering if you and
my other progressive icon i kyle kwinsky
with this white to read
the first draft of my first blog article
on the battle week
sure send it to me through my website i
will take a look at it
um okay do you know how to contact kyle
too i've been trying to get in contact
with him but i just haven't been able to
i do not it would not be appropriate for
me to to
to do that
okay well okay um so
how would i send it for your website uh
you go to the contact page on my website
okay okay thanks i'll just send i'll
it will be it will be about about a week
or so before my
before before i put on my put in my blog
maybe two
two so i'll just send it to you and
maybe you can read it
perfect all right very nice that's a
plan okay and i'll
just i just wanted to say i just wanted
to say thank you
thank you oh thank you again again
because i wasn't i remember listening to
that call
after it was uploaded to youtube and i
meant remember thinking man i was such
an idiot
oh my goodness okay we're going to bleep
that but i appreciate the call all right
john paul jones
uh very very strong i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry for cursing great to hear from
you okay my pleasure
he's shot out of a cannon today that is
really something else